la dernière course c'est l'adrénaline
oxydée donc c'est un produit absolument
banal qui ce qu'on peut fabriquer dans
n'importe quelle pharmacie à partir
d'adrénaline et puis de celle d'argent
par exemple
âgé de haut cette molécule c'est une
molécule très simple c'est neuf H9 et
no3 qui se fabrique en quelques minutes
cette molécule
et donc un dérivé d'un produit
l'adrénaline qui est produit par nos
surrénales les glandes surrénales c'est
ce qui est au-dessus du rein et c'est ce
qui c'est l'hormone qui nous protège
contre le contre les agressions c'est ce
qui nous permet de répondre aux
infections c'est ce qui nous permet de
répondre quand on est soumis à une
agression physiologique donc
l'adrénocombe c'est une molécule
totalement banale qu'on peut produire
dans les 20 000 pharmacies françaises
elle coûte
1,80 le milligramme c'est-à-dire un pain
au chocolat 1000 g on est loin des
milliards de dollars qui ont été
annoncés donc c'est une molécule ces
histoires totalement sans enfant
totalement banale et il faudrait
vraiment être complètement con pour
torturer des enfants de 3 ans comme on
l'a dit sur ce plateau alors qu'on peut
avoir de l'adrénochrome dans toutes les
pharmacies de France ce n'est pas un
produit interdit ce n'est pas un produit
toxicomania il est accessible et il vaut
rien
l'adrénocchrome
toxicomaniaque n'entraîne pas
d'hallucination n'a pas d'effet sur le
cerveau n'a pas d'effet de
rajeunissement aucun la seule chose
à très forte dose elle augmente un petit
peu le pouls c'est-à-dire le rythme
cardiaque peut monter à 80,90 donc c'est
une molécule qui ne sert à rien qu'on
n'utilise pas pourquoi
elle n'est pas l'adrénochrome n'est pas
utilisée en clinique mais elle est elle
est vendue pour elle est vendue pour des
raisons chimiques pas pour des raisons
pharmacologiques elle n'est pas elle
n'est pas dans le dictionnaire Vidal
elle ne sert à rien donc mais si demain
moi je vais voir mon pharmacien je lui
dis je veux de l'adrénade mais tu tu
donneras pas parce que ça n'a aucun
intérêt que ça ne sert à rien je voulais
simplement dire que fabriquer de la
denochrome est extrêmement facile et que
ça coûte rien la dernière commande donc
on va pas aller torturer des enfants de
3 ans pour récupérer une substance qu'on
peut fabriquer en quelques minutes donc
voilà histoire de cette histoire étant
de sang d'enfants totalement inventé on
connaît l'origine c'est quoi l'origine
c'est une c'est un complot qui est né
aux États-Unis et qui est arrivé en
Europe qui est complètement démentiel
complètement fou ça n'a jamais existé
bien évidemment et vous imaginez bien on
a accusé en fin d'émission le président
Macron d'être mouillé dans cette affaire
n'importe quoi
on est
voudriez-vous que on torture
et donc pourquoi irait-on torturer des
enfants pour obtenir une molécule qui
n'a aucun intérêt qui ne sert à rien qui
ne coûte rien et qui est accessible
chimiquement très facilement donc on est
sur un vrai délire et je pense que ça
doit nous servir de leçon il faut faire
attention à ne pas diffuser tous les
délires qui passent et celui-là il est
particulièrement